>> Greg: IF YOU LIVE IN THIS
FORM, YOU DIED BY THE SWAMP
WHICH IS WHY SOMETIMES IT'S GOOD
TO PEEK YOUR HEAD AND SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON DRY LAND, A TOWN
THIS SWING STATE THAT WENT FOR A
TRUMP IN 2016, AXIOS HELD A
FOCUS GROUP OF VOTERS WHO AT
ONCE VOTED FOR OBAMA BUT NOW FOR
TRUMP.
IT'S A SMALL SAMPLE BUT STILL A
WINDOW INTO THE REAL WORLD THAT
MOST MEDIA PREFERS TO BOARD UP.
THESE VOTERS SEE IMPEACHMENT AS
A BUST, A DISTRACTION THAT
WASTES TIME AND MONEY AND WORSE,
A PLOY TO REGAIN POLITICAL POWER
AND SOME THEY SEE WHAT CNN WOULD
RATHER KEEP SECRET FROM YOU.
WHAT DRIVES THESE BELIEFS?
A PROFOUND DISTRUST INCLUDING
THEIR DROOLING IMPEACHMENT
COVERAGE, LIKE SELLING TEAMS AT
COMIC-CON BATTLING AN IMAGINARY
VILLAIN AND THINKING IT'S ALL
TRUE BUT THE MORE THEY ATTACKED
TRUMP, THE BETTER HE LOOKS AND
THE CRAZIER THEY LOOK, THE
ATTACKS COME OFF AS DEEPLY
EMOTIONAL HATRED OF THE VOTERS
THEMSELVES.
THE PEOPLE WHO PUT TRUMP IN
OFFICE AND STILL DON'T REGRET IT
SO WHY TAKE ADVICE FROM TROLLS
WHO MOCK YOU BEHIND YOUR BACK,
YOU SHOULDN'T.
WITH IMPEACHMENT, THE MEDIA OR
KIDS AT THE WHEEL UNABLE TO
NAVIGATE THE TWISTS AND TURNS OF
REALITY GETTING INTO AN IDIOTIC
PREMISE THAT THIS WILL ALL WORK
OUT.
WON'T.
SO EVERY DAY THEY CRAWL THROUGH
THEIR OWN RECORDS BELIEVING THEY
HAVE EVERYTHING UNDER CONTROL
EVEN WHILE THEY FLY HEADFIRST
THE REALITY.
A LOT OF MIXED ANALOGIES IN
THERE.
I STILL LIKED IT, I THINK I MADE
A GOOD POINT.
EVIL FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID
ABOUT MEN AND WOMEN, DANA?
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
WHERE IS THE QUOTE?
WOMEN, I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
YOU ARE NOT PERFECT BUT WHAT I
CAN SAY PRETTY INDISPUTABLY IS
THAT YOU ARE BETTER THAN MOST OF
US.
I AM ABSOLUTELY CONFIDENT THAT
FOR TWO YEARS IF EVERY NATION ON
EARTH WAS RUN BY WOMEN, YOU
WOULD SEE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT ACROSS THE BOARD ON
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING, HE SHOULD
BE IMPEACHED.
>> Dana: HE SOUNDS LIKE A MAN
WHO WAS MARRIED TO HIS WIFE AND
HAS TWO DAUGHTERS.
REINFORCING THAT.
I HAVE A COUPLE THOUGHTS ON
THIS, SO THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
GREAT WOMEN LEADERS, I WROTE
DOWN A COUPLE,
MARGARET THATCHER.
IN THE FIRST DEMOCRATIC ELECTED
WOMEN IN AFRICA, DOWN THERE IN
NEW ZEALAND, SO THERE IS A BUNCH
BUT THERE WERE ALSO SOME THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN SO GOOD SO HOW
ABOUT THERESA MAY?
HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY AND NOT
ABLE TO LEAD AND THEN I'M GOING
TO MENTION ONE OTHER ONE AND
SOMEONE AT THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTED AND
TURNED OUT TO BE AN EVIL PERSON
AND THAT IS OF BURMA, AND
ABSOLUTE DISGRACEFUL PERSON THAT
WE HELPED AND NOW IS BASICALLY
DEFENDING.
SO IT IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
>> Greg: WHERE DO YOU PUT
ANGELA MERKEL IN THIS?
>> Dana: I HAD HER RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE ON THE LINE, SOME
GOOD THINGS AND SOME NOT SO GOOD
THINGS.
THE OTHER THING, I LOVE THE
SAMPLE THEY GOT FROM THESE
VOTERS BECAUSE IT REMINDS ME OF
WHAT HAPPENS IN TEXAS IN THE
1980s.
IN THE 1970s, EVERYBODY WAS A
DEMOCRAT AND THEN REAGAN CAME
ALONG AND HE WAS ABLE TO CHANGE
THEIR MIND AND THEY NEVER LEFT
SO THEY HAVE BEEN REPUBLICANS
AND CONSERVATIVES EVER SINCE.
>> Juan: A FOCUS GROUP IS NOT.
>> Greg: I WILL GIVE YOU THAT.
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S THE CASE
THAT IN PREVIOUS FOCUS GROUPS,
YOU HAD MOST OF THE PEOPLE
SAYING WE CAN'T STAND TRUMP'S
PERSONALITY AND WE WISH OBAMA
WOULD RUN AGAIN, THAT WAS A
REGULAR ONE.
BUT I THINK ONLY TWO OF THE TEN
IN THE GROUP SAID THAT THEY
DEFINITELY WILL VOTE FOR TRUMP
SO YOU HAVE 80% WHO ARE UNSURE
VOICING THEIR OPINION.
>> Greg: HIDING IT BECAUSE
THEY KNOW IT'S AN UNPOPULAR
OPINION IN THE MEDIA.
>> Juan: THIS IS GOING TO BE A
VERY CLOSE ELECTION.
I THINK TRUMP HAS A STRONG
POSITION, HE IS THE INCUMBENT,
HE CAN SET THE MEDIA WITH HIS
TWITTER FEED, DEMOCRATS CAN WIN
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO SAY IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE EASY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE TRUMP HAS SUCH
A STRONG POSITION IN MEDIA, THE
MEDIA IS DEFENDING IN HIS
FIREWALL AT THIS MOMENT BECAUSE
PEOPLE REALLY LOOK AT THE FACTS.
>> I READ YOUR COLUMN AND I
THINK IT'S THE BLACK VOTE THAT
IS GOING TO BRING TRUMP INTO
REELECTION.
>> Juan: YOU READ ONE OF MY
COLUMNS?
>> Greg: I ENJOYED EVERY WORD
OF IT.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT HIS OPINIONS
ABOUT WOMEN OR THIS FOCUS GROUP
OR YOU COULD TALK ABOUT BOTH,
MIX IT TOGETHER.
>> Dagen: IS FINE TO FLATTER
WOMEN, HONEY I'M GOING TO THE
SUPER BOWL AND LEAVING YOU AT
HOME WITH THE KIDS KIND OF
FLATTERY BUT THEY ALSO NEED TO
STOP TELLING MEN WHAT IS WRONG
WITH THEM.
YOU SAW THIS IN 2016 WHERE WHITE
WORKING-CLASS MEN, BLUE-COLLAR
MEN DID NOT GO FOR HILLARY,
THAT'S WHY TRUMP WON MICHIGAN,
PENNSYLVANIA, WISCONSIN.
YOU THOUGHT AGAIN OF THE BRITISH
ELECTION LAST WEEK, STRONGHOLD
FOR LABOR BEFORE WORLD WAR II
FLIPPED TO THE CONSERVATIVE
PARTY, STOP TALKING DOWN TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND TRUMP HAS
A LEG UP AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
NEW MEXICO CANADA TRADE DEAL
WHICH IS A HAND OUT TO THE
UNIONS TALKING ABOUT 76,000 AUTO
JOBS CREATED IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WHICH STORY PIQUES YOUR INTERES
INTEREST?
>> Jesse: HERE IS HOW DUMB THE
DEMOCRATS ARE.
DEMOCRATS ARE SO DUMB, ALL THE
WHITE WORKING-CLASS VOTERS VOTED
FOR OBAMA AND THEN SWITCHED AND
VOTED FOR TRUMP, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE NOW JUST CALLING RACIST,
INSTEAD OF WINNING THEM BACK TO
HIM AS THEY CALLING THEM RACIST
VERSUS THE OTHER DAY AT THE
ARMY-NAVY GAME, CADETS PLAYING
THE CIRCLE GAME LIKE THIS OR
WHATEVER, IT'S A GAME EVERYONE
PLAYS AND NOW THEY ARE CALLING
THEM WHITE NATIONALISTS AND THIS
IS WHY.
TWITTER HAS BEEN SO BAD FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY THINK THESE VEGAN ACTIVISTS
SOCIALIST PHANTOM
SOCIALIST FHANTOM
SOCIALIST FEMNTOM
SOCIALIST FEMINOM
SOCIALIST FEMINISTS HUNT THE
MAJORITY OF THE PARTY AND THEY
ARE FOLLOWING ALONG OFF THE
CLIFF WITH THESE PEOPLE.
ALSO, THEY HAVE CLOSE TO LIVES
THEMSELVES.
ALL THE LEADERSHIP AMONG THE
DEMOCRATS, NEW YORK OR
CALIFORNIA.
NANCY, ADAM SCHIFF, SCHUMER,
NADLER.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE GOING TO
LOSE THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND
TRUMP HAS TAPPED INTO THIS
ECONOMIC POPULISM AND THEY
DIDN'T SEE IT COMING BECAUSE IT
IS PATRIOTIC AND EVERYBODY
AGREES WITH IT, STRONG BORDERS,
LOW TAXES, THE FLAG, HISTORY,
TRADITIONS, LOW GAS PRICES,
AMERICAN ENERGY INDEPENDENCE,
ALL THAT GOOD STUFF, A MAJORITY
OF THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY
WANT.
HE'S GOT.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE EVER GOING
TO TAKE THAT AWAY.
>> Juan: I DIDN'T HEAR ANYBODY
YELL RACISM.
>> Jesse: I HEARD EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THE MEDIA, IF YOU
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP, YOU ARE A
RACIST.
>> Juan: IF YOU EXCUSE THOSE
KIDS AT THE ARMY-NAVY GAME, YOU
WERE GOING TO EXCUSE PEOPLE WHO
DO WHITE SUPREMACIST JESTERS.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE THE CIRCLE
GAME IS WHITE SUPREMACY?
>> Juan: I FIND IT OFFENSIVE.